what do you think what do you think is
the
uh do you have a son or or you said John
right 73 he's born 73 she's 68. yeah
okay so the son that's 73 he asks you
that uh what do you think is the purpose
of a man in like what is my purpose what
am I supposed to do like if you were and
I know you're going to say to each his
own everybody's different some it's
being this some is being that like
what is my you know what what what
purpose do I serve in this world what am
I supposed to be seeking in life why am
I here well if I if I'm your son and I
ask you the question what do you tell
them well I think I think like many
other questions that are being asked
today especially
social media
the question is ceremonial modern is
substantive
I don't think I've ever had a
conversation in which my son would pose
the question what is my purpose as a man
in life
um you only have one sentence
that question I would say hey Dumbo look
at your grandfather imitate that
in fact I think I've said exactly that
your grandfather is a model of what a
man should be why
unyieldingly tough resourceful highly
intelligent honorable
fought in the Foreign Legion got my
mother out of Germany got my mother out
of France crossed the Pyrenees on foot
made a new life in the United States
and
was enormously proud of the fact that he
was one of the few Jews in 1940 to face
the Germans with a submachine gun in his
hands that's enough to be respect of
course salute at the highest level yeah
yeah so that's if my son were to ask the
question how do I be a manager imitate
your grandfather uh David so remember
how he asked you the question what are
some of the heaviest questions at this
age where you're at what what are some
things some strong convictions you had
in your 20s 30s 40s 50s 60s whatever you
pick it that now it's kind of like you
know yeah it's not that important you
know I used to think XYZ was so
important it's really not that big of a
deal that's a that's a very good
question I I except for the the
concluding part I I don't have many
where I say it's not that important but
I have I have many convictions I can
remember
from the 60s
I was when you were 60 or in the 1960s
in the 90s okay
um you've got to remember I was not a
baby boom I was born in 42 so I was
three years older than the Generation
Um to which I was exposed in the
classroom
and uh
I have to say my own defense I was very
suspicious of the 1960s although I
participated enthusiastically and I
encouraged my students to rip up their
draft card while keeping mine pristine
condition God forbid I should go to jail
for my convictions
um and uh
when I heard in 1964 the Rolling Stones
painted black which was a a very popular
song in the 19th early 1960s I realized
that the sexual Revolution was imminent
was about to break loose and didn't take
a whole lot of perspicacity to realize
that
but I must say that all of those
impulses
hedonistic impulses
which seemed to make so much sense
destroy everything rebuild everything on
a peaceful sexually enlightened basis
that held with the family the hell with
commitments the hell with patriotic
concerns simply develop your own
sensibility and live as gloriously as
possible in the satisfaction of any
desire no matter how vagrant remote or
degraded that was part of the 60s and it
came to catastrophe
the 60s did not end well we did
incredible incalculable damage to
American society in the 60s and I
watched it all happen I was far too
jejun or even stupid to recognize it in
front of me even my objections to the
Vietnam War were pure oil
and I thought I thought the Vietnam War
was a catastrophe because I was 1A
I certainly wasn't about to go off to
Vietnam to see my own ass blown off that
was out of the question
my father did not approve of that
attitude he did not approve of that
attitude
he didn't say anything but you know
every son can feel a father's
disapproval
he thought there was something
scandalous about not being unwilling to
defend your country by joining the
military
um
looking back I'm not really prepared to
make a judgment to this day I don't
think the Vietnam War has received the
kind of scholarly attention that it
really does deserve it's too early I
mean the Vietnam War ended in 1973 1974
it's going to take a hundred years
before we really understand
there was indo-chinese Wars of
succession and don't forget they began
in 1945 the French were chased out and
the Americans were chased out but I do
think that in 1962 1963 and this remains
an abiding conviction
not quite an answer to your question but
perhaps illustrates the nature of the
question that no American president
could have done anything other than what
Kennedy and Johnson did do
I think that's that's true and that's uh
a very curious point because it puts the
entire structure of the anti-war
movement in a different perspective
um I have a lot more respect now than I
did in the 60s for my father's attitude
about
honor demanding a willingness to serve a
lot more respect a lot of respect for
your for your father's uh a level of
appreciation as a patriot to what this
country probably gave him and his family
where he oh for sure you have no idea
how it's honorable to have that mindset
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]